okay so we're starting with two weeks of
utilitarian theory this was one of the
major moral theories and often times if
you were to take a different ethics
class who might only study two latarian
ism dan ontology and virtue ethics and
with the addition of ethics of care and
egoism one of the reasons why
utilitarianism
is such an important one theory is it
captures some really basic fundamental
insights figuring out the way that you
ought to be what's right and what's
wrong
that doesn't mean that it covers
everything that it needs to implement
but it's one of the big heavy hitters so
we're starting off with Jeremy Bentham
and remember how to class sessions ago
we did hedonist we did heiress to this
and we did at the epic URIs and I said
this is kind of prefiguring what we're
going to be doing in the next couple of
weeks
Bentham in some ways is like heiress
tifus he holds that the pleasures are
all more or less on the same level
heiress tipless remember let's favor
physical pleasures or mental pleasures
why because they're more intense
getting that Melville is a bit more like
I'm too curious and daddy says no oh you
know the mental pleasures are Hydra
pleasures they're better functions we're
not going to get to the act for another
week so we're going to explore this this
perspective first and then we'll look at
Mills refinements of them yeah
utilitarianism really gets started as a
moral theory as a school of philosophy
in the late you know you conceive say
the late
18th century early 19th century and then
it goes on to the present so Bentham is
one of the big computers John Stuart
Mill one of the next important guys
another person people were not going to
study Henry Sidgwick not often read
these days except by philosophers he
made some refinements to to utilitarian
moral theory and then utilitarianism
influenced a lot of people after that
and there's even very important
representatives today like Peter Singer
for example I heard his name may be
environmental studies classes or food
addicts classes or things like that
those contacts because he had to do with
the shift from focusing on human beings
with utilitarianism to focusing on
sentient beings and gentlemen he's the
guy who came up with the word speciesism
maybe run across that before we're not
specialists human beings Peter Singer
he's utilitarian we can talk a little
bit about it but we have some time so
let's go back to Jericho which of these
quotes is not from Jeremy feather we've
got nature's place mankind under the
governance of two sovereign masters
paying the pleasure the good of the many
outweighs that there's a few and this
long hold I'm not putting
its entirety a man may be said to be a
partisan of the principle of utility lad
the rest of that later which of those is
not backed up himself anybody have any
idea it's drawing out a little bit of
pop culture knowledge from before your
time
are we asking this like 10 years ago one
of them is from the TV show anybody have
any idea which one is from the TV show
yeah the good of the money the good of
the many the good of the many outweighs
the good of the few who said that
anybody know you have to be kind of like
a fan of the show for this to come to
mind but if you were a fan of the show
you would know this this book so I'm
guessing that none of you are Trekkies
Star Trek fans there's the box set that
said it like every other episode in the
old Star Trek right and so did a lot of
the movies that he's in as well because
Spock is basically utilitarian that
comes down to it that's good utility
really good of the many always the good
of the field so if he says this when he
sacrifices his own life for example to
save the show I remove the evening you
know I'm not gonna debate the relative
merits of you know star Trak versus any
of the other sci-fi things that are out
there but I can't say it has not aged
particularly well and now watching it as
chemical but anyway Spock was a good
representative he saw that as the
rational thing to do so if you have to
sacrifice yourself to save 10 people or
a hundred other people or a thousand
other people that's the right thing to
do
on the other hand if you have to
sacrifice some other poor you know
schlopp to save everybody else including
yourself that would also be the right
thing to do it doesn't necessarily have
to be you it just has to be minimizing
the amount of casualties or minimizing
the damage well then they would probably
be good once to sacrifice next next
class we're going to look at what makes
a good person a good person or bad
person in terms of their motives and
dispositions from the utilitarian
perspective utilitarian would be willing
to say there's some people
the idea of a life that's not worth
living also makes sense from utilitarian
perspective to life is mostly just pain
that maybe that's that's not as valuable
as the life that has but we'll get to
that in a moment so all three of these
are pretty representative of
utilitarianism the first one
Bentham is actually saying look when it
comes down to it everything is about
pleasure and pain
he is a hedonist utilitarianism is a
form of hedonism every good that's out
there ultimately reduces to pleasure or
preventing or removing or relieving pain
in some way every evil that's out there
is evil ultimately because it produces
pain not because somebody says that it's
evil not because the law says it's wrong
not because it affects somebody but
because it actually produces pain for
something all of being offended could be
kind of pain intensity other types of
pain so we're going to look at that and
pleasure that we talked about that
already many sense man made may be said
to be a partisan of the principle of
utility and the approbation of
disapprobation again Nexus to any action
or to any measure is determined by a
proportion to the tendency which you can
see is it to have to want meant or to
diminish the happiness of the community
in other words its conformity or
unconformity to the laws or dictates of
moods so a lot of groups right that
probably made your eyes glaze over as I
started reading right some of it are
words we don't even use and what's
what's approbation just approbation
we're gonna mean by those
see
approval and disapproval right exactly
we're praised and we're not praising
somebody to do the ops with me what's up
disapprove so you're very sorry ladies
criticized okay so if you're a partisan
of the principle of utility if you're a
utilitarian if you're using this moral
theory that you give praise or give
criticism all and say something is good
or bad for any action or any measure
based on whether it generally produces
more pleasure or or pain for the people
in the community so he brings up this
term utility utility is the tenancy
smooth reduce budget or you know the
flip side of that same same coin
opposite side to remove pain and I think
it's often useful for us to rephrase
these things in terms of we're more
familiar with we don't talk about it
until a baby right let's you the
Economist's utility functions or things
like yeah most of us are not economists
for you utilities are things like heat
water sewage trash electricity what does
he mean by by utility another you
started something he has utility what is
it
now yeah one letter off be aggressive
you use it's useful ability is useful
it's useful kind of good useful and that
these two pleasure or the removal team
remember last that last class but a few
classes ago we talked in terms
instrumental kinds of goods and then we
also talked about intrinsic inputs the
only things that are intrinsic goods for
a hedonist are pleasure or are the lack
of pain the only things that are
intrinsic evils are balance for a
hedonist are pain or the removal of
pleasure and everything else is good or
bad depending on what it leads to so if
it's useful for producing pleasure then
it's a good thing right so if somebody
is funny why do we like funny people to
make us laugh we like to laugh right
there's a kind of pleasure in laughing
what are other things that we like like
ice cream why is anybody here who
doesn't like ice cream probably don't
like the same flavor funny like thanks
what's up he's good yeah you know what
kind of ice cream you haven't liked
probably tastes sweet there's a few
savory edge
and we like things that taste sweet ice
cream is made I mean even though the way
it feels in your mouth there are
scientists who study how to make ice
cream you have the right kind of texture
why did they do that because that brings
us pleasure I suppose if you were to
make a mechanic you might feel pain
you all see the thing with a little kid
is like you know it's hot day and their
kid starts crying he's feeling pain he
just lost his ice cream and you buy
another ice cream cone your give it to
them
that's a good act why from utilitarian
perspective you just gave him some
pleasure back
you took away some pain it's not good
because it's good to be generous or
anything like that in and of itself
being generous is good because that
tends to produce pleasure being stingy
tends to produce only instrumentally
that's what utility means I was just
wondering what specific things make this
different than contract Arianism I know
that what that has to do with like the
social good leads to your own yeah good
but they don't necessarily specify
pleasure or pain as it's done that's
wonder that's right their social
contract theory it could be framed in
terms of pleasure you couldn't you could
in fact be utilitarian yeah
well seems to have something in mind
like that but it's not necessary social
contract theory tends to say look once
you've got agreements in place those
agreements have to scan otherwise yeah
even if the agreements in general dirt
don't turn out to be pleasurable for
most people think I have a place to
preserve a social worker
whereas a utilitarian would be more
willing to say well you know social
order is good only because it's a
pleasure to get them and if these
agreements have outlived their good time
and function maybe you get rid of one is
more apt to change together I suppose it
really it depends on the focus the
utilitarian is looking to calculate
deciding whether the social contract
area is either looking to talk sure we
make the contract or once it's made
desist fit with a good question okay so
going back to utility gives it a couple
other synonyms he says my utility has
meant that property any object and where
guy tends to produce benefits advantage
pleasure good or happiness and he says
these all about to the same thing so
when we talk about something being
beneficial what do we mean this is
pleasure or takes away pain when we talk
about something being harmful what do we
really mean we mean that it tends to
produce pain or take away pleasure talk
about something being advantageous or in
our interest that means that it produces
more pleasure than pain
something is dis advantageous not in our
interests against our interesting
that produces pain rather than pleasure
or you can think about this in terms of
happiness happiness you see that term
happiness or unhappiness for the
hedonist that just means pleasure or
pain happiness is a state where you have
more pleasure and less pain unhappiness
is a state where you have more pain and
less budget and so these are all sort of
synonyms for each other so he says of an
action that is reformable to the
principle of utility you can always say
either there's one that want to be done
or at least is not one that want not to
be there you can say that it's right
that should be done this is sort of
defining what the words right Blagh want
must what they mean for utilitarian so
you know the basic point of utilitarian
theory is you want always to try to
bring about the greatest amount of
utility it were bringing the greatest
amount of pleasure balanced by the
minimum of paint and you can think about
this in terms of just yourself you know
for instance what are some things that
you have learned over time and three or
you know twenty-five years that could be
pleasurable but you probably shouldn't
do because the end of bringing about
paper never picked something to do and
then later regretted it but this was a
this is a bad
I could come up with lots of examples
from my home but I'd like to hear
suppose your girl what are some of the
things that you've seen yeah oh yeah I
was thinking about that today there's
there's a pleasure in shopping right now
you know some people don't like to shop
but even they like to get apart that's
pleasure getting something for cheaper
than they should be and some people
really like to go shopping and what are
the pleasures involvement some people
just like to walk around look at stuff
those are the ones that the store clerks
come up to and help you know looking
kids for historically the store clerks
are hoping to make a sale then there's
some of us who actually like to buy
things I don't like to shop for clothes
I like to I like to go grocery shopping
you know especially if there's like a
lot of different varieties of things
what makes these artichoke hearts better
than these I actually like comparing
them
I didn't anything yeah you know they
they know that you're not supposed to go
food shopping with your hungry yeah
you can also buy more stuff early okay
I didn't need anything but I was there
you know there are some people that
can't go into a gas station this is why
it's so good that you pay at the pump
these days there's some people that
can't go to a gas station without buying
some of that knick-knack E junk that
they have what good did that do
and then afterwards they think yeah it
really shouldn't spend two bucks a pop
on these key chains I only need one key
chain only one of them actually has a
utility for it I don't get much like got
some pleasure out of buying it because I
like behind guys but afterwards it's
more pain because I realize this is more
job in my place and I don't have that
two bucks that I just blew if you think
about some of the collections that
people
I know some people that have because
they like to buying DVDs and they can
see any movie they want on pretty much
but how many movies can actually watch
and most of movies that you want these
days you can stream them they'll through
Netflix or you know there's a few other
sites that you can do that with get the
library you can get movies whenever you
want right
yeah or you just go red box and rent it
you know so spending the money 16 bucks
to 10 bucks to buy a DVD that maybe you
only watch once as it's going into this
gigantic collection it's only going to
give you the same amount of pleasure
each time you watch it maybe you should
pay less for that box is pretty cheapest
so when you do do it at the balance of
pleasures over pains
now there's another aspect of this
notice that when I brought up this quote
one of the words that I used that
expands this community utilitarianism is
different than just plain
run-of-the-mill hedonism and that it
doesn't just look to the individual it
looks to the whole community looks to
everybody who's affected by the action
or the policy with a choice or the state
of affairs that's being brought about
so you're not just interested in your
own pleasure the toilet area you're
interested in everybody who's affected
and you actually have to balance
everybody's pains and pleasures in a non
selfish way you have to accord everybody
the same consideration as you give
yourself if you're there so you count as
one person they count as one person if
there's two of them
therapy is worse than your pleasure in
doing something then you don't you don't
indulge yourself in that pleasure if you
could team up against you know one other
guy and there's some pain for him and
pleasure for all three of you and your
pleasure outweigh its pain that'll be
okay from utilitarian perspective we'll
look at some of those examples how do we
figure this out then this is one of the
big problems with utilitarians if you
want to try to calculate everybody's
pains and pleasures even if you just
want to calculate your own you have to
have some way of comparing them right
how do we compare things
how many compared goods and services in
ordinary life
shreya these right why why would you be
willing to give this for one thing if
they have something else and that's a
five dollar bill for other things like
you know this is okay to blow on a candy
bar right although for me that still
bothers me because when I was a kid they
cost less of my mindset about what
things should cost is set back then but
this for a candy bar five bucks
maybe at the movies but then you feel
like you're being ripped off right we
think we have ideas about anyone think
is it worth
why is that why is that candy bar worth
a dollar and now five dollars - what can
you get for five dollars more pungent
right the candy bar is not getting you
that much pleasure you get five candy
bars order what's something else that
you can get for $5 it's my joy yeah now
I'm not just a beer but a beer and a bar
right because you could actually get a
six-pack
what kind of beer you're buying right
maybe two-thirds of a six-pack but you
get the idea we have to figure out how
we can bounce pleasures ain't hungry
so bet them says yeah this is a real
issue how do we do it what goes into it
and here he does a lot of hard thinking
about what would possibly allow us to
measure pleasures and things he actually
comes up with something that he calls
the hedonic calculus leave he knows he
paid rusev is pleasurable a big hit on
his butt so he took a Greek word he
looks at for our characteristics
clatters and the first what is intensity
how much of a pleasure is and I think
that you guys can relate to this a
little bit easier how many of you that
are like been in a hospital because not
not because you're visiting something
but something happened you got hurt and
then they ask you what about your being
on a scale of one to ten how much pain
are you and it's kind of hard to figure
out exactly what you should say
especially if you are just being in pain
I didn't realize until I actually saw a
chart that I've always been low-balling
you know when I said like a six I should
have been 38 is like intense
let's say that you've got this church
let's say the charm actually works right
so we get rid of the problem of maybe my
pain is less intense for more intense
let's say we're actually comparing them
than apples to apples basis could we do
that with pleasures to that we cut your
some like a candy bar where a scale of 1
to 10 the pleasure of eating a candy bar
that you like someone you may like
different candy bars pick the candy bar
that you like what would you get two
maybe two three now let's take something
else like having a really nice meal at a
restaurant having a favorite food
favorite dish what about if I gave you
the choice you can have that or you can
have going free tickets to a concert for
the band that you like the most which
would you prefer would would you would
you wave or would it be a difficult
decision for you to make who would like
the meal more
two people who would like the concert
more would be would be undecided would
have a hard time okay
so probably we can say in general and
people would rank concert higher
although maybe it would depend on who
the band is how much you in fact like
them can you think of any other even
better experiences what would you give
us what would you give a 10 to vacation
like a day during your vacation like
being away just relaxing okay
I think that we're literally vacation
like not like a day off of work where
yeah I'm doing nothing like on the beach
with your family where you'd really like
to be it okay that's that's gonna work
in well that's a good segue so pleasure
staff expensive they also have duration
how long do they last
eating the candy bars a short pleasure
right you can always need another candy
bar but now you're talking about another
pleasure and you could have them
together I mean you could have sitting
sitting down like you do that for
Halloween candies but there's a limit to
how much candy you can cram into you
even tear out of your stomach as you
probably realize if you were a kid right
you got sick on Halloween candy the meal
how long could a meal go yeah I mean I
the longest I've ever seen is like four
hours I went to a dinner one time up at
the common area one of those fancy
restaurant
of course and of course and of course
and one of them was actually like not
actually eating the course because
hearing people talk about the things you
know those cheese came from here you
know there's probably an enjoyment in
the hearing about it for account of
sewers I'm not a connoisseur so I'm more
like you I I you know oh it's a long
description cuz I'm actually like to
taste the wine or eat the cheese try the
dish and the other thing is two portions
are kind of small because it's mostly
presentation the concert how long
well you could do the same thing for the
candy bar which maybe may be more
intense pleasures maybe Richard mutters
do stick it on basically for like your
day yeah I suppose if you were going to
something like Monsters of Rock one big
long concert many stages typically in a
concert 3-4 hours I went to the Foo
Fighters a while back and they came out
and they say you know most bands will
play two hours we're not we're not those
bands we're going to play as long as we
feel like playing we want to play for
four hours or four hours
good what about vacation occasions yeah
if a vacation is intense you can pile up
a whole bunch of those tabs couldn't you
imagine going to the spot you've always
wanted to go to or maybe you've already
done there go back that would be that a
candy bar
Raven any in case of candy rather than
to think an awful lot of candy bars to
get you to not go on that vacation then
there's a couple other factors that go
into it that are a little less important
but still are worth mentioning because
of these certainty and propinquity
certainty is the likelihood that you're
actually going to enjoy that pleasure so
community bars they're all pretty much
the same
you buy a whatever it is if you like I
like whatchamacallit the most do you
like I can be relatively certain that
it's gonna be the same taste because
they're all coming from the same factory
unless I buy it like $1 to learn which
case is probably still going on vacation
are you guaranteed they have that great
experience you go on vacation whether it
could be bad give you a lot of jerk
tours there
your family is prone to making a scene
or arguing with each other yeah you
might my name is Louis like a 10% chance
of vacation my family usually join but
I've seen some families where it could
be a losing proposition for pick wadiya
stop closest men we've valued pleasures
that are closer to where we are in time
that doubt that pleasures that are
further up it makes perfect sense if I
walk today or tomorrow or I could have
waited for like another I coulda waited
a week I think it was and we won't have
to worry about my paying for it to end
or anything but I told my mom I'm
competitive they give her the money
either
yeah I think that that is a common
experience that there's a lot of things
that we actually did valium distant
pleasures the same as closeup letters or
same thing with paints too you want to
get away from present pains and pains
that are out to get us do just but you
know it's like two months away and you
get culture to that know you start
sweating and saying cool I don't really
not looking forward to this and want to
get away from this yeah it's like we
were talking about earlier with what
could bring me pleasure and that Britney
pain yeah it's kind of like once I got
my phone away I could have waited the
experience of regret yeah
often times we realize that perspective
we made a bad decision now there's two
other things that he brings up and these
are less to do with the pleasure itself
and Hornady with the context of music
mr. Johnson whether they bring about
other things one is what he calls for
company
and the other is what involves purity
but comedy is the likelihood that
pleasure is going to bring them out or
entail other pleasures purity is whether
that pleasure is free from other things
so let's use the classic example
drinking right you decide to take up
your friends invitation and go out and
have some beers and you know that your
friends are our drinkers so they say
having kind of beer or two they mean
you're going out for the night could
that end up bringing about other
pleasures other than just the sheer
pleasure of your company of drinking
yeah maybe you meet somebody like at the
bar start up a romantic relationship
that would be an additional button right
is it an unmixed pleasure remember
you're going out drinking with people
who you know like to drink a lot what's
likely to happen the next day yeah maybe
they won't
and drink so much you probably will be
that means that the pleasures not
occurring here pleasure there's a lot of
pain matters where you go up with them
and they act like a bunch of jerks
because there's sloppy drunk and that
kind of diminishes your pleasure that
means that your pleasure is less pure so
these are factors to think about and
then the other thing that's really
critical is what he calls extent how
many people does the pleasure apply to
it so let's just assume for a minute and
this is a big assumption they know that
we could actually come up with numbers
for all of these things these fees and
that extent extent is easy just pull
people right let's say we can come up
with numbers for each one so let's just
pretend we're getting a utilitarian
calculation so we have how many students
that's ten fifteen twenty one okay so a
good number for this we're going to
single out one student who wants the
positive so we're going now it's a
Japanese game show I don't know if any
of you ever seen Japanese game shows
they are quite often humiliating painful
they do a lot of things to the
contestants and the contestants quite
often don't even win why do the the game
shows do so well because people like to
watch this sort of stuff so you're not
in the Japanese game show terrible
things are going to happen to you for
the next hour it's going to produce
let's say a thousand units of
displeasure right very intense
displeasure but we're the audience
there's there's twenty eight of us and
each of us gets 100 units of pleasure
watching and all the bad things happen
to you well you know total it up
thousand versus twenty times 100 what's
up mm so really it's a balance isn't it
thousand to the good even though it's a
thousand of the bad for him
overall it's a higher amount of pleasure
you can maximize the pleasure over the
pain that would be a good thing to do
according to that there could be some
other circumstances involved but that
would all have to be a matter of
changing the amount of pleasure or pain
let's say it also may be the family on
the now suddenly there's there's ten
people and they all experience 500 units
of displeasure so there'll be five
thousand so six thousand two the bad
2002 the good now suddenly it becomes a
bad thing you see how this sort of thing
works how this this calculation gets
carried out now let's look at some
actual examples
okay so if you start thinking about the
individual let's think of some some
examples of things you actually find
pleasure
we brought up you know nice nice dinner
waiting to a concert I'm getting a car
what else do you find pleasure yeah
vacation vacation probably a lot of the
vacation is probably a lot of different
pleasures all right probably keep things
here and there but mostly pleasures so
what would be an example let's say we're
gonna try to do this in terms of Bentham
stuff
it's an intensity duration duration
obviously what the vacation if you want
as long as I can so a two-week vacation
is about twice as good as a one-week
vacation seven day vacation is twice as
good as a four nights three days
vacation what else would go into the
intensity what would make for a really
good
oh okay that's that's an interesting one
because remember how we talked about
certainty you don't control the weather
so maybe the the vacation one it could
be more or less intense depending on the
weather and that's kind of chancy let's
say it's a 50/50 chance of good weather
I mean you can't where you're guaranteed
good company okay that would probably be
one of those matters that was common for
coming you have the pleasures of your
friends do with that go on vacation or
making make new friends right go on
vacation now you have all these other
pleasures that come with maybe you're
the kind of person who likes meeting
people you enjoyed that could be an
additional pleasure that comes yeah so
like the whole Catholic religion is
based on like for dying for all of us to
live oh that's a minute that's a very
interesting question John Stuart Mill
certainly thought so and he tries to
make an argument that if you're a
Christian you have to be
to a period most Christians don't think
that's the case part because you took
you know utilitarianism boils things
down into pleasure and pink and makes
those the ultimate arbiters yeah well
you can find some Christians who do
think of things in those terms
traditionally Christian ethics has been
thought of in terms more of like
obedience to God's law or cultivation of
virtue and when it supplies or are doing
one's duty so much more in terms of the
other ethical systems a good question
big question now that one we could
actually take my whole class time to
answer category bring back on vacation
now what else what else makes for a good
vacation
oh yeah and that would be I guess you
could look at that remember in terms in
that cost to give anything so you're not
otherwise you're kind of losing out on
some sort of pleasure that the wedge we
have or it would be some sort of King
her hurts a little bit to give the money
away for the vacation but if you're
getting bargain that feels good and if
you're getting it for free that really
right that could make that's getting to
do the kinds of things you like I
imagine and some of you probably enjoy
the beach some of you like people
watching others watching all those would
go into this and all those could be
components the utility oh my god
vacation if somebody were to like like
you're talking about somebody were to
give you fake Asians away why do we see
vacations and as good things to give
away why are they prizes instead of
penalties because they bring about more
pleasure than pain for the people that
are concerned now let's think not just
in terms of individuals let's think in
terms of relationship we have more than
one individual concern because remember
the utilitarian is not just interested
in how affects you personally but how it
affects everybody who's concerned so one
of the great examples that I came up
with not myself but it actually came out
of somebody's book that I'm reading
he was time
it's talking about this is an ethical
issue think about breakups when you have
a romantic relationship
people are deed why why did breakups
occur
yeah I think it's probably more often at
least in my experience looking at my own
life my friends lives Rock the one
person is more favorite than the other
person that's why the other person tends
to be counting down so why do people
differences okay might be differences of
pleasures and pains you know all you
want to do is play xbox all day I'm not
into Xbox that much that's a reason to
break up with something do is drink all
day that much in a drink when you have a
break up if you think about it in terms
of pain and pleasure
so part of what is the one who's
breaking up with a party to party to is
definitely going to Hanna right because
they're being broken up um once they
were just waiting for that other person
so hopefully you know drop the boom and
finally break up with them so they can
be free and they didn't have to have the
guilt if you don't like breaking up with
the other person themselves which does
happen sometimes right these are the
things sitcoms we made up
generally the party was broken up with
as long as heart is broken and they
experienced a lot of pain right 31 may
may be experiencing some pain but why
are they actually usually breaking up in
the person they're trying to and some
kind of pain right and I can't stand
being with you you're driving me nuts
those are reasons people break up with
each other
what are they saying therefore the
ability Rhian part of you I'm
experiencing displeasure in this
relationship I would like to no longer
experience displeasure I would like the
relationship to end that's what they're
saying
they may also experience some cruel some
people
Cyrus don't they I think you've seen
that before haven't you
at least they appear to be okay or maybe
make some feel important to do the one
breaking up with the other person people
very couple of each other for all sorts
of reasons or maybe they want to pursue
pleasure I think we should see other
people
what's that say when somebody says to
the other person in their relationship I
think that we you would mean LA to see
other people what are they actually
saying I would like to see other people
are they actually saying I think it'd be
a really good thing for you to see other
people now I'm making this great
sacrifice of breaking up with you so
that you can see other people that might
make me happy
is that the way it works what do you
think if you again to decide between
option option one is I think we should
see other people means I'd like to see
other people or option two turfs I think
we should see other people means I think
it'd be a really good thing for you to
see other people
don't worry about my feelings which do
you buy
how many raise your hands only option
one how many option two but we're
crashing right I think it's because I
mean there could be somebody that does
that but that's pretty great now look
this is really interesting to think
about from utilitarian perspective let's
say the breakup is going to happen how
should one breakup with the other person
are there any rules yeah
I think you're right if we're looking at
this from the utilitarian perspective
one ought to try to minimize the
inevitable pain that's going to come
about before the person who's going to
be hurt yeah yeah I think oftentimes
they yeah that's the heart of the answer
I'm not like you know the sociologist to
my general experience when people say
it's not you it's me
they mean it's you but they're trying to
save the other person's feelings let's
say let's add a few other riddles to the
person who's breaking up with the other
person has met somebody else they're no
longer attracted to party - they're
attracted to party 3 should they tell
them that from a utilitarian perspective
it would really depend wouldn't let's
say we're in a huge city like like New
York City and when people break up with
each other's unless they choose to see
each other out where they hang out the
same places they're probably never gonna
see gently should that should party one
of the break-up tell party too that they
found somebody new that is the object of
their affections
say something heads shaking why not
what's that likely to do yeah you might
you know if you're cruel do you want to
get back together or something like that
maybe you say that the reason you do
that is because that will give them more
employment and for military perspective
you want to minimize the amount of pain
maximize the amount of pleasure and the
relationship now what if it's a small
town do you think that changes yeah I
mean if you let's say that somebody used
that it's not you it's me excuse but
it's really because they wanted to date
somebody else yeah it's a small town and
now you know you run into them at the
restaurant the bar the County Fair or
whatever it happens to be and you see
them with this other person your party
Tuesday and wait a second I thought you
you wanted you wanted some space to be
alone or something like that now you're
dating this other person that you were
spending a lot of time with before then
you're more hurt right but if this
hasn't happened you think about you know
sitcoms
that's a great example of the kind of
situation in which it's not so much a
matter of trying to maximize pleasure
it's more a matter of trying to minimize
pain now let's look at some sort of
bigger picture issues and we will do
more of this let's say we're thinking
about community and we're thinking about
this sort of big moral issues that
people want to talk about when we talk
with ethics classes
let's take we have a whole bunch of
different possibilities
how many people live in the world I mean
it's a problem exact statistics how many
billions seven ability not too long ago
six I remember when I cross that line so
there's seven billion people and of
those seven billion how many of them not
too many right how many of them are what
we like classify as poor if we use our
own standards of people on average two
televisions how many
most of them yeah it's probably a good
guess you didn't even break this down
this is doing very very well
there's about let's say 1 billion we're
doing pretty good there is what we call
the developed world you know
States Europe Japan other Australia
other parts of the world standard of
living is pretty high in those areas
Singapore I think counted as well they
do have some people who are poor but
most people in those areas have pretty
good lives on average compared to
everybody else there is about another
billions who are just horrendous
circumstances anywhere from living in
refugee camps to living in war zones
chronic states have been security
poverty poverty that goes back
generations after generation after
generation lack of access to clean water
without food a lot of the time yeah
these are
there's about 5 billion they're more or
less in the middle and they're doing
let's just say so so I mean the
conditions are actually improving for
people globally and they happen for
quite a long time for most people in
most areas standards of living happened
in the middle class has been developing
in countries that didn't previously have
wealth is being generated you know
infrastructures gain generated people's
standards of living are our improvement
they're not great but you know they're
not that horrendous gas there was war in
the redness area and much less over here
is this a fair distribution from
utilitarian respect
you think that's why the people were
living the well-off lives so they seemed
particularly happy it's interesting if
you look at Western democratic cultures
people don't seem to be more
particularly happy with all the things
that they have than the people in this
five billion in other countries and we
could type a line that sometimes this
whole literature out there these people
clearly have got a terrible and they
experience an awful lot of pain is there
pain offset by the you know massive
increase in pleasure over here unless
there is in a very high amount of
pleasure over here
that's probably ready to highway how
could we change this let's just think
about food
over here what's the big problem obesity
people in the third world are often
amazed that people not just in America
in Europe in Japan and all these other
developed countries can have to have you
know problem with obesity what's the
problem over here it's its scarcity its
hunger is there actually enough food to
feed everyone
yeah at any given time there's there's
always enough food so what if you could
redistribute things why don't you change
the food distribution patterns so that
let's say for example it's you know
instead of doing a lot of military
operations that we do let's say we gave
some of our troops or a variable train
to UN peacekeeping forces and use them
to go to these countries where they send
food over there sometimes they can stall
in warlords take it solid let's say we
actually use military force to make that
happen to make sure that people would
actually get fed and change that would
that be a good thing to do from
utilitarian perspective the right thing
yeah because you would be increasing the
total not pleasure decreasing the total
amount of pain that would be the right
thing to do for me to attend respectful
another example let's use effects
communities
one issue that often comes up in ethics
classes is which is you know massively
proliferated because the Internet is
pornography a good thing or a bad thing
according to utilitarian standards well
let's let's think about this in a
somewhat different way than we do with
population
and does anybody feel pains anybody
negatively affected I mean why do people
why do people buy pornography or agender
was it tight tried to eat what does it
have to do our sexual right so why are
people looking at sex is one of the
things that we enjoy somebody's never
fear there wouldn't be for the hottest
right when our connection goes all the
way back to ancient Greece and Egypt you
know there are pornographic or erotic
art works back in those times Pompeii is
a great example an uncovered Pompeii
they found these you know dirty pictures
people having sex why do people have
that why would somebody like
commissioned an artist to produce that
well he was followed by consumers
consumers are getting some sort of
pleasure right anybody else getting
pleasure
yeah sure call the producers
distributors tough lifestyle counseling
I read the high burnout rate which might
tell you something right
one of the things that's really
interesting to see of these these these
porn directors they asked these these
difficult questions to in interviews
like would you let your daughter started
moving there always freedom of
expression this is a great thing with
liberating sexuality and then yes how
about your own daughter
I don't think let me ask them why not
what's you know what's the maybe this is
where we should get to who is negative
who's negatively affected by yeah
okay stars with ours
and we'll say family because it's more
oftentimes the working conditions are
not very good some of them end up
getting diseases as a result a lot of
the industry because of the internet
take a very simply exploit
other places not realizing what they're
getting into we're starting for anybody
else was bad
one of the arguments that was made for
being much more lenient getting rid of a
lot of the wasp nests
was that it was going to improve
people's marriages who's been delivering
to see what other people do you know get
people away from their sexual hang-ups
that sort of thing so it seemed to put
it pleasure set right
what a social scientists tell us about
the effects of is it good for marriages
in general isn't bad for marriages in
general this might you might just be
able to common sense
what do you see a few people saying yeah
yeah there could be some good
consequences coming in general it tends
to where there's a lot of writing about
those rumors it's bad for marriages
relationships to produce a culture in
which I mean men are sometimes
objectified report but it's mostly women
for underclass reform right
that's where the standards are put out
there is what a woman ought to be like
or you know how how relationships want
to be going and those tend not to be
very healthy standards those tend not to
be they seem like they're liberating in
one sense but they often this is what
people say often end up becoming much
more constrictive much more restrictive
closed options
woman and they they produce Pinker so if
you already until it's um you would
actually have to look at whose pain and
pleasure balances up if you can show
that overall there's still more pleasure
than pain then then you shouldn't have
them if you can show that it actually
generates more pain than others overall
then maybe utilitarian would actually be
in favor of getting rid of Carmen
start with I mean you can look at the
individual what should I do
you know thinking about my own pleasure
pain I'm going to actually skip over
that just to save a little bit of time
I've talked about this
there's your pleasure let's say you're
in a relationship to be a friendship the
romantic relationship could be business
partnership know it's not just your
pleasure and pain accountable right now
there's at least one other person
today's Valentine's Day let's say we
have some generic
so the question is should you follow the
time-honored custom of doing something
for the person who you're involved with
or the person you'd like to be maybe
somebody who you were involved with or
you can take all sorts of permutations
right well let's think about this are
there multiple things you can do what
are some of the things you could you
could do for balance let's say you were
really cheap yeah
and let's say something they can tell
you did at the last some people like
that's true but generally when people
like homemade things you're like well
made do it though me sir not not
throwing together at the last minute out
of whatever craps I had at the time you
can think about the homemade thanks to
addresses if you you know you could
write it at home if you're good at rain
poetry you know and the person that
you're involved was likes that sort of
thing then that can be really effective
now let's think of some some grand
gesture things
there are some some big
learning Valentine so that happy very
usually cost like a dollar cost like $10
I am NOT farmer geologist that yeah yeah
like that they're gonna die and I stay
but you spend $70 on the plan is it's
been like you take a ride through
Central Park restaurants is hardly the
reservation but of course you could do
nothing - right with all these different
options now let's say you were party
once you have to figure out what to do
for they expect something let's say you
do the homemade thrown together at the
last minute thing what's the outcome
probably like we produced pleasure for
them
it does let's say they're sort of the
typical weight like we're going
the other possibility of buying some
sort of other grand gesture you can do
pretty tough to do outflow on short
notice right I you know I would suggest
them do a dedication on a radio station
now I know you know one of my favorite
Valentine's Day presents I got as a kid
was actually that's true yeah you can
look around for like deals things so you
do nothing now doing nothing that's no
doing nothing means if you don't have to
think about okay how is that going to
turn out the party to be some sort of
pain involved right thing right
disappointment
maybe he's trying to hint that you're
supposed to do something and you're
gonna dig up the cancer I mean
relationships are full of this work no
one said you make some sort of grand
gesture well you can certainly to solve
the right to the pleasure doing that
okay so make it feel good as a matter of
fact if you don't do it I think you're
probably gonna so there's pleasure and
pain mix there's probably some pain or
outweighs lack of pleasure and then
you've got to devote some time and maybe
some money to it but I mean over overall
it's probably gonna be a pleasure and
how people feel when they do something
really nice for somebody the other
person reciprocate they cocaine at that
if they do there's something wrong they
generally feel pleasure and we're not
going to try to assign units or anything
deafness we're gonna keep it really
simple so what would Jeremy Bentham say
for Valentine's Day
yeah try to find something something
good to do if you have any good
suggestions
we'll wait till like after class but I
think Jeremy Bentham would also saved a
good thing for you to give them to your
fellow classmate that would be giving
her pleasure right and it doesn't cost
you anything so let's look at one other
example so we have relationships we can
also talk about
the wider community people who are
affected by a lot of different examples
down here let's think about engaging in
more right because this is what this
will be a good one to sort of turn out
on our heads
we've been involved in two iraq wars in
the last twenty years we've been
involved in war in Afghanistan with
smaller actions here and there with
different things let's say that the goal
putting a put aside all but you know
back and forth abundance over this over
this let's actually say that the goal of
invading Iraq watch to get rid of a
tyrant who is causing a lot of
displeasure amount of pain to his people
and tracking neighbors and that sort of
thing what were the trade-offs so but
you do you can do utilitarian stuff in
terms of like it's healing pros and cons
so let's do it in terms who's affected
in terms of clutter who's affected
Hey
it was benefited by the Baath Party
regimes what's up it's a dance family so
there aren't what he said benefited by
the regime being not really being thrown
right there's people who were like in
prison for political reasons okay
yeah in general at least for the first
part of the general population was happy
know who wasn't happy right everybody
who worked for out of power that was
quite a few people
someone actually managed to good jobs
pretty pretty decent general D
pacification what else is in the - we
had to spend some some money and some
blood on it right and we had to take
money away from other things
Americans who would have otherwise had
that money going to the safe social
program if it's like that be pumped into
non war sector now if you could show
that that this amount of harm or pain
was less that this amount of benefit or
removal of pain or even pleasure a lot
of people really happened that Saddam
was going because he was he was a brutal
tyrant it's made you know the Baath
Party I don't know if you know this
modeled itself after the Nazi Party they
explicitly incorporated some of that
into their the radiology if this is
smaller than this that it was a good
idea to do what we leaving out though
we've yet you know thousands of gates
right how many casualties to the racket
said hundreds of thousands yeah even in
the first Iraq war where we have like
only a hundred cattle teaism also not a
friendly fire we kill over a hundred
thousand people one way or the other
most of them who work guys that were
just taken off the street and put forced
it to the army and they bomb them and
buried them under you know dropping
bunker-busting bombs on them you if
you're a utilitarian you have to include
everybody's pain and suffering not just
the out of your on the side if you're
making policy so that might tip the
scales right we could phrasing also in
terms of other things you know the
invasion went pretty good guys this is
going back ten years so this is when you
guys were in middle school
the invasion itself went pretty good how
do things go after that not managed well
maybe if we had managed that better we
could have changed the general balance
of maybe from utilitarian perspective
there was a moral requirement to
actually get not just the invasion but
the occupation if you're going to invade
somebody's country
do a lot of damage to the infrastructure
and that's one thing
maybe there's no moral responsibility
than to make sure you would build it the
right way not just sort of make it up as
you go along which turned out to be
unfortunate yeah that's one thing you
could look at as utilitarian as well
there's a lot of other issues that we'll
explore if that's Terry when she can
punish people how should be distributed
resources or how should be distributed
you know harmless to the two different
people but could you make an argument
for justifying legalization of drugs we
can look at some of those things later
the main thing to keep in mind is you're
always going to be doing something like
this you're always going to be totaling
up who's harmed
yeah who's benefited and you always want
to try to minimize the arm and maximize
the benefit understood in terms that's
where will they offer it today